Well,
I don't know if there's a single model
we'd want to learn from.
I think you want to take bits and pieces
from,
from a number of different models.
But I think if you look to Europe,
I mean some of the things you could say
pretty much across the board,
I'm thinking Western Europe,
obviously the countries that are closest
to the u s and living standards that
they do work many fewer hours.
And that is something that I think
people,
their value,
the idea I know may Europeans,
they're,
they're amazed.
They,
they I think made them,
don't even believe me when I say that
people here don't have the cations.
I mean,
obviously a lot of people do,
but there are many tens of millions of
people that don't and there's certainly
no guarantee of a vacation.
Um,
so paid time off that people know they
could get four or five weeks vacation,
which is absolutely standard in Europe.
Some countries,
Denmark has six weeks.
Um,
so I think that's something that that's
very valuable.
Give people time off.
Um,
again,
parental leave,
uh,
this is conservatives like to see a
women stay home with their kids.
I don't care whether it's women or men,
but the idea that people have that
option,
I think that's very good because it's,
it's a real strain for people to juggle
a job and work.
Um,
so that makes a big difference.
energy use a Europe across Europe,
average energy use,
greenhouse gas emissions,
about half of what is the United States.
So even though they're very comparable
living standards,
they use much,
much less energy.
Part of that is that they have more mass
transit.
Part of is it's more concentrated,
uh,
people live closer together,
which,
uh,
people wrongly in the United States,
it's because we're such a big country
that's really not the case.
And obviously we're a big country,
but that's not why we're so spread out.
We have land use policies that basically
promotes sprawl.
And in Europe,
they've quite consciously designed
policies that have been intended to
fight sprawl.
And I think it would make sense for the
United States to do that as well.
Make it easier for people live in the
cities.
Um,
make it easier or near in suburbs rather
than build out 90 miles,
have people commuting an hour and a half
each way each day.
So a number of different practices that
we could take from across Europe.
And again,
I don't think any single country we'd
want to hold up as a model,
but I think they're common practices
that take different forms that we could
look to across Europe,
Canada,
all.
So I mean,
it's not just Europe.
Uh,
we really are the outlier among the
wealthy countries in a wide range of
areas.
The World Bank I think is often played a
fairly pernicious role over the last few
decades.
Uh,
billy,
uh,
supporting a lot of bad projects,
development projects and make great
example here is Chad building an oil
pipeline.
There were,
everyone knew what the garment Chad was
corrupt and the world make bank made a
big,
big point of insisting that they were
going to have all these safeguards to
ensure that the,
the money from the pipeline went to,
uh,
helping the poor people in Chad,
one of the poorest countries in the
world.
And Lo and behold,
what happened was the money went to the
government.
They used it to buy arms.
Um,
you know,
that,
that's just an example.
I mean,
they've had things like that all over
the world.
They've also promoted and a wide range
of areas where I think it was often
inappropriate at one,
I'm most familiar with the social
security in Latin America where they've
got an almost every country in Latin
America.
Brazil is the big exception to either
wholly or partially privatized their
social security system.
And almost invariably it's led to very
high costs,
poor coverage rates,
really not very good outcomes.
And they've done that with water
systems.
So they,
they very much promoted an agenda,
which certainly serves a lot of
corporate interests,
often has not served the people who
they're supposed to serve,
which is the poor of the world.
So in principle,
I mean the World Bank's mission if you
go into the building.
And it really is kind of remarkable
because it's a very opulent building.
I mean,
no one objects to people having nice
offices,
but it's really quite opulent with this
big fountain,
big atrium.
And,
um,
up on the wall it says,
our dream is a world free of poverty.
And it's,
it's just a,
it's a,
it's amazing they did that and there's
no sense of irony to that.
Um,
anyhow,
I mean,
their mission is a very noble one.
Unfortunately.
I just don't see them having done very
much to advance it.
Okay.
[inaudible].